ah
you
Dina's face this is an angry face does
this face look happy to you did think so
okay we are playing slender we're going
to play slender the original slender III
of that I can play slender or can play
paranormal again would you guys like to
see some paranormal or slender I think
everyone said slender anyway so I'm
gonna play the original slender because
I have yet to beat that and I want to
beat it I want to beat it badly
slender paranormal paranormal slender
paranormal slider paranormal slender
paranormal I've actually seen more
paranormal paranormal paranormal
paranormal slender slender slender
paranormal amnesia come on have you not
been paying attention max come on get
with the picture here alright we're
gonna do paranormal because there's not
much left to paranormal and I kind of
want to get more going on with
paranormal so one second while I get
that fired up yep paranormal then once
we get all the scares that are involved
in that game then we'll move on to
something a little more slender type so
mmm where did I put that oh yeah I
remember now
all right O's that's the one mmm
hmm
yes yes yes yes again sorry about the
problems that have been going on with
okay ow my ears all right let's go to
switch up some stuff here blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and
then crank that down and then put it up
and then get out of that ah what bull
honkey
oh god every time I hit escape closeout
it again which it lovely lovely one
second
mmm no kidding you don't see the game
wow you're so observant about one second
I got a somehow alt-tab ear there you
okay took a clever use of mechanics here
and now I did the cam
boop-boop-boop-boop about that how about
them apples
how about that yeah I am definitely
definitely definitely going to be
definitely going to be investing in a
new computer very very very very very
soon so look forward to that now I don't
really go to cons much so yes turn your
volume actually this this is pretty loud
anyway so I'm gonna
all right crank the volume just deplete
squeeze down okay now are you all ready
are you ready to go are you ready are
you ready ready
no not ready all right here we go
hmm you may use bull honkey to your
heart's content
it's a Friday not that way first that's
your line no lies hello my name is
Mattel Clark you're gonna die I'm an
artist tell you know and I've come to
believe that my house is haunted nobody
believes you lately things have been
going bump in the night you're an a-hole
a lot so I've set up cameras around my
studio and I've got one here and I've
started recording things to try and
prove to people that I'm not going crazy
yeah yar this is the studio um this is
where the magic happens don't mind the
posing mannequins I picked those up at
Amazon they help me visualize a 3d space
when I'm working on my sculptures right
some works in progress over there on the
mat mm-hmm hopefully something will
happen here in a second yeah really
trying to show that this is real and
then I'm not trying to get famous on the
Internet yeah if I was there I'd punch
every ghost in the face that's what I do
oh I know I guess I should change wait I
should change what game I'm playing on
Twitch now ass not a big deal
it's not to do okay so there we go now
whoa oh yeah the wall was that well I've
never noticed that before
okay yeah that's normal that's normal
yeah I think the activities are quite
random when you play least I believe so
apparently there's a lot of stuff that
I've probably never seen
Oh what the hell that is fall Oh a
little statue bump
really this guy's so short and weighs
10,000 pounds hi my water turn out don't
mess with my water what I don't care I
like here look at the fridge it's upside
down what the hell
dot you rain affects dog who's that
hello Tristan peace boy okay I done that
already that before
yeah this is Wow this was made in the
Unreal Engine so the Unreal Engine has a
lot of really cool hi August 11
well no no I've already have those notes
me turned out oh my
what the hell who put these chairs here
who did this oh calling me
can I hang up now thank you okay
perfectly normal everything in you know
what I tripped why did I trip huh God
see that one before
Kali oh man hi what are you doing dick
what hi
oh that's my pride and joy or something
latter ease you're getting low okay I
better charge it when I go to bed
tonight alright let's get upstairs
let me uh what DEP phone off phone okay
how do I get out of that tonight
can I get out of that my battery my
battery you know battery hey can you hey
can you get out of it please
Oh God uh no got back into the use of a
[ __ ] yeah get out of it get out of it
what is wrong with you get up.get
okeydoke it oh god what the f would net
and now my camera is going jerky all
over the place okay
still normal perfectly normal and let me
check the bathroom because I still got
some time
hello ha
okay no time out of time out of time
snarf yeah after I saw that baby paja
it's uh the lady after I saw that baby
pop up I did yeah I would damn for sure
be good
yeah I can change cameras how do I
change cameras space II how do I change
cameras hello hello everybody thanks for
stopping by
hi baby
blood okay
huh that's nice I remember this ha ha
I don't remember the head friggin poking
out of the door goddamn yeah yeah okay
I'm not gonna oh come on
really this guy is gonna be thank you oh
hi that was my chair is people messing
with my chairs I know too far five and
oh can I can I escape a thank you ha get
out of here all you want mess with me
huh
don't mess with me guy here yeah
now I thought I see one small problem
here let me fix this clip okay much
better if anyone knows who is it just a
pixel sliver above my head June 27 no
time to read those stuff to do
Oh oh hello hello okay enough of that
hey I can pick it out up not bad not bad
whoo
car starts on its own a well what
how strange
I'm uh haha I am not too comfortable
being in this house I'll tell you what
hello I know okay someone said that
there was an attic scare but I've been
up here like quite a few times I've
never seen it like before in my life I
met up and down there my new 10 times oh
there's more mannequins there's a lot
more mannequins I know that they're
everywhere when I hear the baby cry yeah
I don't want to do that house is evil no
joke hi rose petals
bomp
all right nothing in this July fourth
nineteen eight you leave no you leave no
you there is no heaven huh interesting
ah put my groceries away
hi gone how do I put my groceries away
how do huh how do I do that
oh I'm proud I'm trying I press E and I
don't know I'll press C crouch
that's Crouch don't don't don't
alright
Oh for camera change I know I gotta go
to bed hook hook up up up I'm so fast
huh bring on time
ah guy here got my way please thank you
Oh drop kick the [ __ ] out of you
I'm into bed ah yes ah the kitchen eh
oh I'll press f.c unpleasing see
f see I'm pressing f MC oh no not this
place again oh boy oh never saw that
before okay so this guy's here ladders
up there fire in the corners doesn't
burn mannequins up there fire over here
yeah okay I don't think I could I want
to get out you're acting like I wanna be
here I don't course I don't
and there's a weird handprint thing I
remember I was just trying to be here
and then was that and I just ended up
having to wait I don't know why
now I'm just a neck sticking out of the
ground it's like a night gun
maybe that's the old ladies or the
ladies nightgown on oh yeah perfectly
normal
I gotta want it
Oh one freedom let me out yummy other
please anybody anybody at all okay I
guess I'll just take this moment to talk
with you guys anyway if you don't know
who I am my name is markiplier I run the
YouTube channel markipliergame if
anybody is new here happy for you to
join me anyway ah ha oh there we go ha
ha
what's better oh look see my camera my
camera battery indicator is is gone
here's my camera battery indicator is
gone behind me
we're looking all around me don't sleep
you know tell me what to do let's
usually I have no idea of when I'll need
the battery battery sleep it out huh I
will uh I'll give that in just a second
I can pick up a fish why would I want to
pick up a fish oh I picked up a fish Oh
as in collectible I got you
oh that's happy fun times all right so
anyway um okay never check the bathroom
first I'm gonna assume that I'm still on
the clock with the camera battery here
so I'm just gonna go I got bail what I
do not
this is utterly confusing got mail where
where do I got mail where how hello
hello no you leave okay no no go to the
attic now I didn't hear a bit what was
that the pipes Oh No basement
Oh
oh the basement okay I know about the
basement how am I still alive I don't
know are you still alive I'm a survivor
all right I know this come on come on
it's a safe I know it's a safe hotel
pipes why I don't know I won't let I'm
gonna go I'm I'm gonna actually go
upstairs and try to sleep cuz I'm a cuz
uh-oh who do that ah screw you I'm going
to bed god I'll die don't sleep oh no oh
no you guys screw a
oh come on it's too late now
oh hi go there's my head ha ha ha ha
happy fourth of July
Oh God
alright that was my mistake Oh God
oh yeah alright I'm gonna move on to
slender getting out of here
I said get out of here yeah alright
moving on to slender oh okay
slender is coming up you can hear it
can't you you can hear it now you can
see it okay
all right so anyway Oh what is this $20
mode everyone's been telling me about
$20 mode I have no idea what that is I
don't know what $20 mode is and I
apparently can't do it anyway it's a bit
high hey gang no $20 mode no it's not
here I don't have it I don't have it go
have it I don't have it I don't have it
okay have to beat it first well that's
never gonna happen for as long as I live
anyway anyhoo let's get started I
suppose
all right here we go got a map in my
head I might take a left this time run a
circle do good someone told me that I
need to turn off my lap my light in
certain points don't contain my battle
Reid I know the map it's all ingrained
in my brain whole brain juices flowing
real good up here oh you believe in me
thank you so much that means so much to
me oh all of I am following a path I
know this is scary tree goes from the
truck and the trailer to the truck and
then moving forward along that oh and by
the way guys oh I'm gonna die there's
like no doubt about that by the way guys
if you want to help keep me alive and
probably raise money for a new whole new
computer actually then there's a little
donation widget down below that's not
for the charity stream let's see at the
end of the month but if you want to help
me out that would help keep me fed and
warm and alive but no pressure in that
if you want to save your money for
charity at the end of the month I'm
perfectly okay with that - okay there's
no page on there haha the amazing things
that happen when you follow the path
that's amazing
almost like it was designed this way
Paige Paige I am not partnered with
twitch I am not no Paige oh come on oh
there we go
don't look or it takes you okay the road
actually is a little bit over that way
oh I hate that thumping oh man
yeah sadly I am NOT partnered on twitch
which means I don't get any money from
this so any donation at all would
greatly help okay wait bigger this way I
go this way I think that way cuts to the
center of the field where the building
is I should get to the next truck and
then it's the yeah I'm not I've never
been that adamant about all right give
me your money it's it's really okay if
you if you can't donate that's fine I'm
just happy that you guys are here anyway
I mean heck we got 750 viewers that's
awfully a lot
come on truck gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme yeah yeah like a
mouse
okay everybody has been saying I should
play $20 mode but such is not the case
nah chicken this is here a chicken ah
you gotta be kidding me
and did not just crash yo son of a [ __ ]
I will destroy your face and I will
destroy everything you love and hold
dear god damn it I I am having the worst
I was hoping that this stream would be
like hey everybody
Oh so great we're all getting together
and having a good time here so happy
that I can do this awesome Horror stream
for you but apparently I can't pay la
can god I'm taking a right go ahead the
right dildo and I'm gonna go to the
rocks I'm gonna go the plus sign
I'm gonna go the tunnel Alan go ahead
guy let's just say Slenderman got my
computer before he got me this is why I
need a new computer truer words have
never been said I suppose oh man
I blame AMD as well you don't know about
the red dildo oh here it is it's this
big red building right here yeah I don't
know about the red build Oh
it's your mom's buy a console F that not
a console game my computer's is very old
and it's been through the rigors of
overclocking so overclocking if you know
you you do it right it gives you good
performance boots but it kind of reduces
to the life of your parts they can get a
bit unstable especially graphics cards
so anyway hello I know there are many
people here tonight I'm very happy but
people are stopping by turn it off for a
second click I can't tell if it's much
brighter still all just dark anyway your
darkness it's it consumes me okay I know
the rocks are coming up on the right
here pretty soon
I can't run well I don't know
aha dev rocks I love to rocks lick lick
lick lick oh that is much brighter at
least I think it is okay so I do got to
turn it off quite often yes giant
pillars of poo see
it makes Slendy oh I did not know that
about that whoo
oh by the way I do see that people are
donating me which is like really really
awesome thank you guys I can't see how
many right now because I can't obviously
get out of the game but you know but
seriously guys it's it's amazingly oh
man it's a mitten all 30 bucks thank you
guys so much 42 Wow thank you guys so
much it I really am gonna put all that
towards uh looking at the ground can't
give me if I'm looking at the ground
right ha ha
hey guy your secret Slenderman yeah but
good seriously I am I'm seriously I got
it it's um been about two and a half
years since I upgraded my computer and
it's it really is time that I do that
I've been putting it off for far too
long okay
plus sign is nearby as are the giant
pillars of poo the plus sign is just up
here in this clearing up here good look
at the ground
oh hey Wade Hey bad things are happening
Wade bad juju up in here no click ah
much better
I don't like these
Slendy got me at two pages up here
before oh please tell me there's a page
on here Oh new yeah just me dying don't
look or it takes you I got
Oh
kliklak can't see can't see can't see
can't see can't see can't see Kensie
running running running running honey
honey honey honey drink up quicker
where am I where am I where's the road
there's a road
ha ha ha ha ha ha got back on the road
yeah okay that's Lindy
oh man thank you guys so much for
helping out with donations if you don't
know if there's a widget just down there
help me raise money for a new computer
that has a worthy cause I suppose the
pillars of Poosh should just be in there
somewhere to the left here I'm not sure
exactly where but I know they're in
there ah god I don't know where though
ha ha ha look at that the ground ok
gimme can't kidney ah
no oh it's not so clearing that's a
clearing that's a click I know that's a
clearing but he's right there always
right there where to go did I get turned
around oh crap ah
Koza poo poo pillars pillared poos
ha ha ha ha pillars fillers he'll be
right behind me he's right behind me
isn't he running he's right he's right
time he's right behind it right
I mean oh come on oh page garden guru
running running running running running
running running running back to the road
I don't think there was a page there
back on the road okay
just head this way oh just go uh goodbye
me nah he's got there quickly I don't
know if it is actually helping me I got
$200 from someone wow that is incredible
thank you oh man send me an email if you
if you donate that much send me an email
at mark Claridge gmail.com I mean that's
really really incredible it helps me a
lot
okay I like this this tunnel looks good
he lied off that's okay it's the thought
that counts
ah oh oh no I'm gonna get off the road
oh no ona road road road road road road
road road road road road road road road
road I've been running a lot too always
so gonna get me he's gonna give me he's
gonna eat me alive he's gonna roast my
chestnuts on an open fire I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die
don't turn off flash
uh-huh why aha
why why shouldn't I do that that a bad
idea ho oh boy no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
I I have lost frequently at five of
eight I think the most I've ever gotten
was six of eight on this one I don't
know someone told me I need to recharge
my batteries or something I don't know
people are stupid Fiddler's stupid
if I turn off the oh come on
III gotta be what was that thought I
heard something your chipmunk or
something
all right cuz where's that damn trailer
was supposed to be right here
the trailer was supposed to be right
here and it's not here and I feel like
he's right behind me I think I want to
run and I want to run I want to run I
want to run hit right behind me I know
he is where is it and rather the tray ah
I should've ran crazy eyes it ran I
should've ran Oh God I didn't look
behind me I didn't look behind me at all
oh man all right take two three
okay so what is the strategy Dwight do I
not turn my flashlight off or do I keep
my flashlight on yeah and II should kept
crashing because my computer is turning
into a giant pile of [ __ ] I need to get
a new computer real soon which is fun
for me I love building new computers but
it's also expensive than I don't have a
lot of money so man I'll try but it's a
lot riding on I mean I'm I'm usually
good at this lender game but for some
reason this one throws me I just ah for
some reason this particular game just
messes with me and I can't seemed it I
can't seem to win I just can never win
with this one I know the oh there it is
how did I miss that right there how
about I'll hit I'll hit this and then
the truck and then I'll go into the
house see how that works out
well apparently there's a lot riding on
me getting eight of eight this time so I
hope I don't disappoint
aha I'm gonna try I'm gonna try to get
eight of eight but man diggity
turn it off early once you start picking
up a lot of pages don't turn it off okay
turn it off early I'm gonna hit the
truck then I'm gonna go the building I'm
gonna swing back up to the tunnel and
then finish the circuit okay
all right I'm getting very conflicting
suggestions in terms of how the
flashlight I'm just gonna leave it on
yeah I don't know I don't know okay
after this one I'm gonna hit the house
I'm gonna da I can run so I'm just gonna
turn straight into the forest and just
head for the house
I know the Morse breathless I know that
I do know that I know I know people
saying they're gonna donate money if I
beat slender but I'm pretty much
counting that I'm not gonna get that
money cuz I'm pretty sure that I suck at
this game I suck pretty bad and I don't
like woods
don't like it
I like the woods okay here's the
building on the building get what's in
there and then get out and then go to
the tankers hit the tunnel again get out
of here
so basically after five pages I
strategically sprint to get the hell out
of there all right I'm a goofy goober
yeah you're a goofy goober yeah we're
all goofy goobers yeah you figure if you
get few feet come on I've three notes
three three three three whopping notes
oh come on come on give me a note give
me a guess darn note uh job' now behind
me not yet not not yet anyway there was
a note what there was a note where where
where how can I not see these notes it
was a note round a corner alright I know
I can never like spot the notes in this
where where wait huh where where where
where where wherever I don't see it no
on the other side right
we're what are you talking about what
are you I I don't see a note you guys
are not helping you guys are not helping
there's no note there you guys are not
helping at all
it's not on the chair you guys are just
give me tankers
tankers do you have any oh it was not
there it was not there I looked it was
not there there's a note you guys are
trolling with me got to control it with
me oh man I'm just gonna head south now
cuz I'm already pointing I'm gonna hit
the red dildo and then loop up back that
way and hopefully I can finish off by
the time I get up there there's a note
where where okay since the road is the
road there's the rocks a crap no I went
east not south oh crap
alright the only way the only hope I
have is to go down get the red red one
red dildo and then spread up the way
gotta hit the red dildo and then go up
because that's the only circuit left and
that means that that one the rocks on
the plus sign another one and the tunnel
I don't know do the way gotta get the
red dildo gotta hit the red dildo oh my
flashlight is not doing so hot
watch out for a bit
hi red dildo should be up on the right
somewhere here somewhere here I know
keep on I got this should be somewhere
here pretty soon anyway
ah okay please come on come on
hahaha okay now strategic sprinting to
treat zigzoo for sprinting back to the
path sprint along getting away from
Slendy man find the path super sprinting
at least it's not like Slenderman where
that guy couldn't run to two seconds
this guy can sprint for a while that's
actually some good printing this oh yeah
the rocks uh-huh the rocks oh no come on
come on come on yes yes yes yes yes no
no no no bread flap crazy get back to
the road road road road road road road
road road road huh I'm an American wait
a minute boom a new burger
good I'm gonna marry okay nose a while
until I get to the plus sign I know this
I know this
I know this serpentine ah you silly
[ __ ] wait is this it is this is it's a
this is a clearing to the plus sign
isn't it isn't it isn't it isn't it
please tell me it is it's not it's not
Evan it's all a lie it's all a lie
oh no it's nothing stuff it was not a
lie
oh please be here oh please be here I
won't make it
oh thank you very much oh seven seven
seven
Oh run run run run run run run run run
back to the road oh my god oh I can make
it looking back it I can make it those
bright out where's I oh no no running
backwards running Oh No he's right by me
I can't sprint anymore I can't sprint Oh
No
ah I didn't turn around I turned around
to run and then I couldn't run anymore
obviously Oh God
alright alright let's do it again
ah alright so the ones I hate the most
I hate the absolute most are the frickin
plus sign and the tunnel what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna hit the red dildo go up
to the building go up to the tunnel and
then loop all the way back around I'm
gonna beat this no I won't beat this
drama beat this what am i raising money
for a new computer cuz this one is
starting to stink oh man
there is the first page
oh I just got caught in that bad spot if
I just oh man if I hadn't sprinted like
immediately I didn't know he was gonna
spawn in front of me like that
oh my god oh God all right effects there
should be a road or a path leading north
somewhere here
don't be like this where's the freakin
Road where's the road there it is okay
yeah here's the path I'm gonna take this
to the building oh oh yeah thank you
guys some what why not that early not
that early your oh come on gotta lights
lighting you are show down your throw
down I'll throw down with you I'll throw
down with ya huh
go yeah huh good for me god damn it
all right Chris I'm running up to thee
aha here's the building give me in it
let me inside yeah thank you oh this is
the front entrance okay how did I miss
them how did it I don't know I don't
know I don't know how I already missed
them frickin Frick I unless I don't know
Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige
Paige Paige Paige okay okay all right so
now I just go look around I poked around
thing then I turn I turn around and I go
up north way to get to the tunnel
I got this I got this
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha
leave you alone leave me alone leave
everybody alone Slendy nobody likes you
anyway I'm gonna go up hit the tunnel
and then loop make the full loop okay
that static but I saw static I'm just
going to cut through the building
okay how long will I be live-streaming
this is probably gonna be the last
attempt guys just to let you guys know
okay the tunnel should be up here right
wasn't it up here yep
sorry I got I got stuff to do I still
have a record for tomorrow's video so
you want that you want you want videos
tomorrow right right right
oh come on where are you no no no oh
come on
we're right in final Road that's just
fantastic Slendy you're an [ __ ]
aho oh we're the frigging tunnel where's
the tunnel aw come on
how can I miss that tunnel it's gigantic
it's enormous
what Oh what how did I get here I don't
know I don't even know but I know the
tunnel is this way I don't know I don't
know I don't know anything anymore
I don't even claim to know anything
anymore I know halfway done
okay so that okay I think this way will
be the tunnel
um how hard is it to find the tunnel oh
man okay
yeah pair of paranormal ended with me
being stupid
no oh here oh oh I don't want to hear it
I don't want to hear it I don't want to
oh I hear no aah oh you don't even don't
make me I would don't oh oh no oh oh no
oh no oh you're not gonna you'll say
word about me I'm gonna uh
oh well I can't end on that note
oz it's horrible alright same strategy
except this time not gonna miss the
tunnel Oh goddamn oh I'm so bad now is
so bad oh man I cannot believe I did
that I ran right into him right into him
oh man okay just gimme head dildo
slender man with Paula Deen's face I
don't know if that'd be scarier probably
no really slender man than hair anyway
yeah I was going out what I was doing is
I was making a strategic advance towards
Slendy I was gonna punch him in the face
like a punching and um yeah he I killed
him
that's odd leave the game ended that's
what happened to punch him right in his
face I got turned around didn't I
where's the road of the road that's a
road that's not the road oh crap oh crap
no forget that fella
darling oh no that's alright haha I
panic way too easy i panic a little too
easy
yeah yeah I punched him in the face
and then I punched him in the nards and
then I oh yeah yeah yeah I killed him
yeah it's weighted okay there's the
house that means the things are down
there this is the right or the left
entrance I can't tell I think it's yeah
I think it's the right I don't know
either way he's going the house see what
top nope
nope nope I hate this house
hey there's also much design stupidly
nobody likes it big dumb but nope no
it's not gonna get me I'm - what up ah
yeah winner on the best
where were you get [ __ ] yeah here ah
okay look at the tankers and I'm gonna
go up there Tom I know are the tallest I
already hit up the red dildo what am I
gonna do for Halloween I don't know
thinking like that yeah yar yar indeed I
was thinking I'm not a pirate at all
I was thinking probably the medic from
tf2 since people think I look like that
already make for an easy costume well
not easy but
a rather appropriate costume okay if I
go up this way there should be a path
here somewhere
either way somewhere this should help me
get to the tunnel I know I think this
yeah this is it this is it this is it oh
yeah totes mcc's croats don't get me
right to the tunnel
mm gonna get me all up in that tunnel
Duffman I don't think anybody has been
Duffman for years
anything at all yeah oh look at that
page all up in that tunnel Oh looking
good up in that tunnel hmm I do do I
already did a frequently asked question
video about myself oh yeah oh yeah you
like this my pages from the tunnel
rocking this hardcore halfway there
alright now I'm just gonna hit up the
plus sign because I don't think that
there's anything at the giant pillars of
poo and I'm gonna make strategic
Sprint's all the way to the winner's
circle all yeah I'm the best I'm the
best there ever was okay now I just got
to find where that pathway is to the
plus sign
I'll be golden I'll be more than gold
why am I gonna die well probably cuz I'm
bad at games and stuff a totally
unskilled and big loser
oh no no no ha ha Oh can't get me I'm
too smart for you ha ha just clearing
all this clearing to the plus side I
know it the pillars I don't think the
pose of the face this time because other
places have had good page distribution
yeah that uh I got it I got it I got it
I got it I got it
I have played Bioshock yes ok this is 5
so when I hit 5 that's when I start that
strategic running strategic running ah
no strategic running strategic running
like up boughs back on to the path oh
yeah then I find the rocks and then I
get the one from the rocks then I run
more where the rocks where the rocks
strategic sprinting Oh like a boughs
right and a slender is ugly non-existent
face you can't go get me this time
where are the rocks they're the rocks
okay I'm gonna preserve my sprint I am I
know I know what I'm doing kind of not
really I but I have an air of confidence
which is so important in success in life
and general stuff like that okay worthy
I don't know he was in front of me or
something
it was nothing it was something all
right I don't know I'm gonna lose him
and the woods in the woods in in the
woods in oh crap ah I'm back on the
right path question mark I have no idea
really I don't know I kind of got turned
around
come on oh oh well yep all right I tried
I tried all right that is the end of it
that is the end of the stream
yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep
yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep it
anyway sorry about the whole amnesia
thing not working I really was trying to
get that to sort it out but
unfortunately such is not the case
I'm I'm glad that I was able to get
something else for you but I really
intended to just do amnesia and I'm like
I'm kind of bummed out that it's not
working like that cuz it's kind of gonna
force me cuz it's something that I want
to do and you know I've had problems
with it before but I actually do one
upgrade soon so your donations do help
so let me let me look over who actually
did donate ten dollars from Anna gold
steals ce o--'s thank you so much five
dollars from double-a dogs thank you
again so much 20 dollars from my
pangpang my pet vieng thank you again
thank you guys
two dollars from martin past year thirty
dollars from tommy franken thank you so
much these are all gonna go pretty much
straight to new graphics card first and
then computer next so thank you guys
you're the best ten dollars from Daniel
Herndon fifty dollars from Nicolas pure
Nicolas card he's actually donated to me
before so thank you God thank you guys
so much you guys are literally really
are the best fans I could ever hope for
and if you don't know who I am if you're
new to stream my name is markiplier I
run the YouTube channel markiplier game
you can there's a link in the
description below big YouTube button you
click on that that's what I'm all about
so do dollars from Rachel Wood Eck thank
you guys so much you really are the best
no I can't I can't keep streaming
I gotta go do something or more
recording for the channel and whatnot so
and next week I don't know if I'll be
able to get it next week but anyway
thank you guys thank you guys so much
for everything that you've helped get to
this point I mean it's been um it's
amazingly fun to do these students for
even if it's even if my equipment is
breaking down on me I'll get it all
sorted eventually but you know I will I
will have it done eventually so thank
you all so much for watching love each
and every one of you guys can't ask for
better fans so thank you thank you thank
you thank you alright so I am done for
this livestream yeah yeah those those
headphones are hard to wear for a while
but anyway so I will have this all fixed
for the next livestream I will get this
livestream uploaded to YouTube as soon
as I can hopefully later tonight but
anyway thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye Tolu bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye